Adam Grant was teaching his first class at the Wharton Business School when a student came up to him with an interesting proposition. He says, I've got this big idea. Three friends and I are going to start an online business and we're going to disrupt an industry. Do you want to invest? But from what Adam could see, this group of friends wasn't doing so well and getting that big idea off the ground. Six months go by, it's the day before launch, they still don't have a functioning website. The whole business is a website, that's literally all it is. And so I obviously passed on the investment. The name of the company? Warby Parker. They were just named the most innovative company in the world by Fast Company and they're
亚当·格兰特（Adam Grant）正在沃顿商学院教他的第一节课，这时一个学生向他提出了一个有趣的提议。他说：“我有一个绝妙的点子。我和三个朋友打算开一家网络公司，我们要颠覆整个行业。你想投资吗？”但在亚当看来，这群朋友在将那个伟大的点子付诸实践方面做得并不好。六个月过去了，离发布日只有一天了，他们甚至连一个能正常运行的网站都没有。整家生意就是一个网站，字面意思就是这样。所以我显然拒绝了这项投资。这家公司的名字叫什么？Warby Parker（沃比帕克）。他们刚刚被《快公司》（Fast Company）评为世界上最具创新力的公司，而且他们的
worth over a billion dollars, which is why my wife handles all her investments now. I'm Shankar Vedantanthan and this week on Hidden Brain, Originals, how to spot one, how to be one. We bring you my conversation with Adam Grant, he's a professor at the Wharton School of the University of Pennsylvania, and he's the author of the new book, Originals, How Non-conformist Move the World. I asked Adam what the Wabby Parker episode had taught him about the qualities of innovators. They often procrastinate and that's how they incubate ideas.
市值超过了十亿美元，这就是为什么现在我妻子负责他所有的投资。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam），本周的《隐藏的大脑：原创者》（Hidden Brain Originals）将探讨：如何发现原创者，如何成为原创者。我们为你带来我与亚当·格兰特的对话，他是宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院的教授，也是新书《原创：非同凡响的人如何改变世界》（Originals: How Non-Conformists Move the World）的作者。我问亚当，沃比帕克这段经历教会了他关于创新者怎样的特质。他们经常拖延，而这正是他们孕育想法的方式。
What parents can do to nurture originality in their kids, their parents focus more on values than rules. And the downside of marching to the beat of your own drum. One of the risks is, you know, you have everybody marching in a different direction. Looking back now, Adam, looking back if you could go back and talk to the old Adam, what would you tell that Adam? I would say that I was totally wrong about what it takes to be original. I think of original people as the non-conformist who drive creativity and change in the world. And I would say they often procrastinate, and that's how they incubate ideas.
父母可以做些什么来培养孩子的原创力，他们的父母更关注价值观而非规则。以及特立独行的负面影响。其中一个风险是，你知道的，每个人都朝着不同的方向行进。现在回想起来，亚当，如果能回到过去跟过去的亚当谈谈，你会对那个亚当说些什么？我会说，我对于成为一个原创者所需要的东西完全弄错了。我认为原创者是那些推动世界创造力和变革的非传统主义者。我会说他们经常拖延，而这正是他们孕育点子的方式。
They feel the same fears and doubts that the rest of us do. They just manage them differently. They hate taking risks, and they have lots of bad ideas, and that's how they get to the good ones. I have to say though, it's possible that when someone sits in an idea for six months and they're an online company and they don't have a website ready to go the day before launch, it is also possible that they could turn out
他们和我们其他人一样，也会感到恐惧和怀疑。他们只是用不同的方式来处理这些情绪。他们讨厌冒险，他们有很多糟糕的想法，而这正是他们找到好想法的途径。不过我必须得说，当一个人把一个点子搁置了六个月，而他们又是一家网络公司，并且在发布前一天还没有准备好一个能用的网站，他们也完全有可能最终
to be a gigantic failure. You're just trying to make me feel better about my decision, right? Would you have invested? I would not. Yeah, I mean, of course, it's possible that they would fail, but what I should have paid attention to is they also met all these other characteristics that originalists tend to bring to the table. So a lot of times you see that originals are not the people with the deepest expertise, the people with the broadest experience. what was so great about Niels background is he had been selling glasses in the developing world And also giving them away to try to help people who couldn't see get their lives in a place where they could work and He had all sorts of exposure to the fact that you can make glasses a lot more cheaply than the monopolies here in the Western world
变成一个惨痛的失败者。你只是想让我对自己的决定感觉好一点，对吧？你会投资吗？我不会。是的，我的意思是，当然，他们有可能会失败，但我应该注意到的是，他们同时也具备了原创者通常会带来的所有其他特征。所以很多时候你会发现，原创者并不是那些拥有最深厚专业知识的人，而是那些拥有最广泛经验的人。尼尔的背景之所以这么棒，是因为他在发展中地区卖过眼镜，同时也把眼镜免费送给那些视力不好的人，努力让他们过上能够工作的生活，并且他充分接触到一个事实：眼镜的制造成本其实可以比西方世界的垄断企业
We're doing it. They were also really good at questioning the status quo and this is a hallmark of being an original a lot more cheaply than the monopolies here in the Western world were doing it. They were also really good at questioning the status quo, and this is a hallmark of being an original. A lot of people would just say, you know, glasses cost what they cost. You know, your doctor prescribes them, and that's the end of it. And they had 60 years of combined experience wearing glasses. But suddenly one day, one of the founders Dave said, why do they cost so much? Like they've been around for 800 years, and they're still more than an iPhone,
低得多。他们也非常善于质疑现状，这是成为原创者的标志，其成本比西方世界的垄断企业要低得多。他们也非常善于质疑现状，这也是成为原创者的标志。很多人会说，你知道的，眼镜该多少钱就多少钱。你知道的，你的医生给你开处方，事情就结束了。他们有加起来60年戴眼镜的经验。但突然有一天，创始人之一戴夫说：“为什么它们这么贵？它们已经存在800年了，而且还比一部iPhone贵，
that doesn't make sense. And once they did research into it, they found out that they could do a lot to lower the price. And I think that was a sign that they were going to take off. In your book, you find that the writer and poet, TS Elliott, Google's co-founder Larry Page, and the... All have something in common.
这没道理。”一旦他们对此进行了研究，他们发现他们可以做很多事情来降低价格。我认为这是一个他们将要腾飞的信号。在你的书中，你发现作家兼诗人T.S.艾略特（T.S. Eliot）、谷歌联合创始人拉里·佩奇（Larry Page）以及……都有一个共同点。
When they have an opportunity to dive headfirst into something, take a big risk, they actually hedge their bets and hesitate. So can you talk a little bit about that? Because that runs counter to the way we think that people who are true originals actually behave. It does. I think what happens is they are afraid of failing, just like you and I might be. And at first, when they have a new idea, they're
当他们有机会一头扎进某件事、冒一个大风险时，他们实际上是在给自己留退路并犹豫不决。所以你能稍微谈谈这一点吗？因为这与我们认为真正的原创者实际表现出的行为方式背道而驰。确实如此。我认为发生的情况是，他们害怕失败，就像你我一样。起初，当他们有一个新想法时，他们
not sure if it's going to succeed. They have no idea whether they can support a livelihood based on it. So T.S. Eliot, you know, poetry is not the most lucrative career. He works as a bank clerk to cover his bills and give himself the freedom to do something original as a poet. And, you know, I think Larry Page and Sergey were both in the position of saying, look, what we want to do is we have lots of great ideas. They were PhD students at Stanford at the time they came up with the idea for Google. They were, and you know, they thought search was bad, and they wrote an algorithm to do it better based on, you know, pages linking to other pages, being an indication that a page
不确定它是否会成功。他们完全不知道自己是否能靠它维持生计。所以T.S.艾略特，你知道的，诗歌并不是最赚钱的职业。他做银行职员来支付账单，并给自己作为诗人的自由去做一些原创的事情。而且，你知道的，我认为拉里·佩奇和谢尔盖当时都处于这样一种境地：听着，我们想做的是，我们有很多好点子。在他们想出谷歌的点子时，他们是斯坦福大学的博士生。他们是，并且你知道的，他们认为当时的搜索做得很糟糕，他们编写了一个算法来做得更好，依据的是，你知道的，网页链接到其他网页，这表明一个网页
was popular. And they didn't see that as a career. They just, you know, kind of said, I know a better way to was popular, and they didn't see that as a career. They just kind of said, I know a better way to do this, and they built it. And they weren't ready to make the leap. They had visions of continuing to just create knowledge. And finished that PhDs, as doubtless their parents would have wanted them to do.
很受欢迎。他们并不把这看作是一项事业。他们只是，你知道的，说我知道有一种更好的方法可以……很受欢迎，而他们并不把它看作是一项事业。他们只是说，我知道有一种更好的方法来做这件事，然后他们就把它建成了。他们还没有准备好迈出这一大步。他们幻想着继续创造知识。并完成他们的博士学位，毫无疑问，他们的父母会希望他们这么做。
Yeah, I maybe still want them to do. Ha-ha-ha-ha-ha. Great advantage of waiting to make that leap is you don't feel the pressure to rush it to market. If they were depending on this for their livelihood, they would have said, we need to get this search engine out there, we need to get it there now. And because they weren't doing that, it was much easier to say, you know, let's get this right. And again, I mean, when you look at what people are doing in basements and in garages,
是的，我可能仍然希望他们这么做。哈哈哈哈。等待迈出这一步的巨大优势在于，你不会感到将其推向市场的紧迫压力。如果他们指望这个来维持生计，他们就会说，我们需要把这个搜索引擎推向市场，我们现在就需要。正因为他们没有这样做，所以更容易说，你知道的，让我们把这个做好。再说一次，当你看人们在地下室和车库里做的事情时，
this is what countless people do. I mean, they have a day job, they're working as an accountant, but they're playing in the garage or that basement and trying to build something new. Yeah, worked out okay for a film night, right? He sold shoes out of the trunk of his car for seven years. Working a day job as an accountant before he finally started Nike.
这是无数人在做的事情。我的意思是，他们有一份正职，他们是一名会计，但他们在车库或地下室里玩耍，试图建立一些新的东西。是的，耐克创始人菲尔·奈特（Phil Knight）的结果也还不错，对吧？他连续七年在汽车后备箱里卖鞋。在最终创立耐克之前，他一直做着会计的日常工作。
And he learned a lot in those seven years that increases chances to succeed. So what makes the switch between the point of which you're sort of saying I'm still tinkering versus I'm actually going? What happens to the people now who just procrastinate and think and plan and endlessly work in their garages? And the people who say, I'm going to work in my garage for the first two, three, four, five, six years, but eventually I go out and test the waters.
他在那七年里学到了很多东西，从而增加了成功的机会。那么，在你所谓的“我还在摸索”和“我真的要行动了”之间，是什么促成了这种转变？现在那些只是拖延、思考、规划并在车库里无休止地工作的人，与那些说“我将在车库里工作前两、三年、四年、五年、六年，但最终我还是会出去试水”的人之间，发生了什么变化？
I think what happens is the fear of failing gets overtaken by the fear of failing to try. And so, you know, if you have a great surgeon or you believe that a film you're making is going to change the world, then at some point you shift from worrying about, you know, regretting, making a fool of yourself, to regretting, never taking a chance. And as you know, that's what psychologists consistently find about regret, that a lot of people are afraid in the moment of taking the risk, but that in the long run our biggest regrets are in actions, the chances we didn't take. And I say, yeah, it might fail, but that's still better than failing to matter.
我认为发生的情况是，对失败的恐惧被未能尝试的恐惧所取代。所以，你知道的，如果你有一个出色的外科医生，或者你相信你正在制作的电影将改变世界，那么在某个时刻，你会从担心“后悔、出洋相”转变为“后悔从未抓住机会”。正如你所知，这是心理学家对后悔的一致发现：很多人在当下害怕冒险，但从长远来看，我们最大的遗憾是不作为，是我们没有抓住的机会。我说，是的，它可能会失败，但那总比未能产生影响要好。
One of the things that you find in the book that I found very intriguing is that very often people who launch new ventures or new careers or new social innovations don't actually choose to do it themselves but they are drafted by other people. Yeah, I was so surprised by this. Michelangelo got commissioned to paint the cysteine chapel and he's looking up at the ceiling thinking how in the world could I do that? And he's terrified so so he flees to Florence. And then he sort of gets coaxed back and talked in to giving this a shot. Martin Luther King doesn't want to lead
你在书中发现的一个让我非常着迷的现象是，非常经常地，那些开创创新企业、新职业或新社会革新的人，实际上并不是自己选择去做的，而是被其他人征召入伍的。是的，我对这一点感到非常惊讶。米开朗基罗受委托去画西斯廷教堂的天顶，他抬头看着天花板，心想我怎么可能做到这一点？他吓坏了，所以他逃到了佛罗伦萨。然后他被哄了回来，并被劝说尝试一下。马丁·路德·金并不想领导
the civil rights revolution. His first dream is to be a pastor and then a college president. And he shows up at a meeting and he's been voted unanimously to lead this movement and basically dragged into it. And so what you find is often people then rising to the occasion when they sort of placed at this position that's in some ways an unfamiliar position.
民权革命。他的第一个梦想是成为一名牧师，然后是大学校长。他出现在一次会议上，结果被一致投票推选来领导这场运动，基本上是被拉进来的。所以你发现，通常人们会在被置于某种在某些方面有些陌生的位置时，不负众望。
It is, and I think this is sometimes what makes them so effective at these leadership roles or at innovating that they've spent months or years stewing on these ideas, and they've hatched by the time that somebody pulls them into the spotlight. And that leads to the question, when you have an organization and you wanna try and get the best talent, maybe the thing to do is not sort of put a job out and say who applies for it,
确实如此，我认为正是这一点有时让他们在这些领导角色或创新中如此高效，他们已经花了几个月或几年的时间来琢磨这些想法，当有人把他们拉聚光灯下时，这些想法已经孵化成熟了。这就引出了一个问题：当你在一个组织中，想要尝试招募最优秀的人才时，也许应该做的不是发布一个职位说“谁来申请”，
but actually to be drafting people who might not on the surface seem like the ideal fit. I think there's something to be said for that, that, you know, originality is brewing in all sorts of unexpected places. And so often, as leaders what we do is we stifle that as opposed to trying to unleash it. And, you know, there's a lot that can be done to try to figure out, okay, who are the people that, you know, are in a position to bring really new ideas into this organization? And why aren't we hearing from them?
而是去物色那些表面上看起来可能并不那么完美契合的人。我认为这种说法很有道理，你知道的，原创力正在各种意想不到的地方酝酿。因此，作为领导者，我们经常做的是扼杀这种原创力，而不是去释放它。而且，你知道的，有很多事情可以做来弄清楚，好吧，谁是那些有能力为这个组织带来真正新想法的人？为什么我们没有听到他们的声音？
Susan Cain, the quiet author, is fond of saying that there's zero correlation between who's the best talker and who has the best ideas. And that's a widely supported empirical finding. And I'd love to do a better job identifying that silent minority and giving them the floor. You have to ask how this reflects on our political system, Adam, where the ability to speak and win a public debate is often integral to winning public office. Yeah, you know what I would love to see is a political system that's based more on skill in leading than it is on speaking. So what I want to know is what politicians are going to be the most effective decision makers, who's going to come the most effective decision-makers,
安静的作家苏珊·凯恩（Susan Cain）喜欢说，谁最会说话和谁最有好点子之间，相关性为零。这是一个得到广泛支持的实证发现。我很希望能更好地识别出那个沉默的少数派，并把话语权交给他。亚当，你不得不思考这如何反映了我们的政治系统，在这个系统中，演讲和赢得公开辩论的能力往往是赢得公职不可或缺的。是的，你知道我希望看到的是一个更多地基于领导技能而不是演讲技能的政治系统。所以我想知道的是，哪些政治家会成为最高效的决策者，谁会提出，谁会成为最高效的决策者，
who's going to come up with the best strategic vision, who has expertise in handling conflict. We don't see that right now. And I think we also look for people who want to step forward. We look for the person who puts up their hand. We look for the person who says, I'm the most qualified person. And of course, it's nice to hear initiative, it's nice to hear drive, but that might not actually be the best person for the job. Yeah, the people that I'm most excited about for are the ones with no interest in the
谁会提出最好的战略规划，谁拥有处理冲突的专业知识。我们现在没有看到这一点。而且我认为我们也在寻找那些想要主动站出来的人。我们寻找举手的人。我们寻找说“我是最合适的人选”的人。当然，听到进取心是很好的，听到动力是很好的，但那可能并不是真正适合这项工作的人。是的，我最看好的人是那些对这份工作
job whatsoever. I don't know how we get them on the stage. Right. Because of course, having the most compelling speech doesn't necessarily qualify you to know what to do when there's a civil war in Syria. I want to vote for the candidate who is willing to contradict him or herself, right? And admit to being wrong because, you know, some people call that flip-flopping, I think if it is enlightenment. I mean, of the people in your book whom you look at, how many of them have that kind of evolution, if you will, whether you sort of try something, it doesn't work, they try something else,
毫无兴趣的人。我不知道我们怎么能把他们弄上台。没错。因为当然，拥有最引人注目的演讲并不一定能让你具备在叙利亚发生内战时知道该怎么做的资格。我想投票给那个愿意与自己矛盾的候选人，对吧？并承认自己错了，因为，你知道的，有些人称之为立场反复，我认为这是一种开明。我的意思是，在你的书中你观察到的人里，有多少人有过那种演变，如果你愿意的话，无论你是尝试了一些东西，它不管用，他们又尝试了别的，
it doesn't work, and they're not actually rigid in their thinking, but they're actually open to being adaptable. I think that's one of the hallmarks of being original, is being flexible enough in your thinking to admit, you know, this was wrong or this was a bad idea, right? Abraham Lincoln, when he came into the presidency, he was initially not going to abolish slavery. He was afraid that it would destroy the union. And he agonized for six months over that decision before he finally signed the Emancipation Proclamation. He's a flip flopper, right? That's one of the most important acts in the history of this country. Thomas Edison, to go to the innovative domain. Edison worked on all sorts of failed inventions
它不管用，而且他们的思维实际上并不僵化，而是真正乐于适应。我认为这是原创者的标志之一，那就是在思维上足够灵活，能够承认“这是错的”或“这是一个坏主意”，对吧？亚伯拉罕·林肯（Abraham Lincoln）刚当选总统时，他最初并不打算废除奴隶制。他担心这会摧毁联邦。在最终签署《解放宣言》之前，他为这个决定痛苦了六个月。他是个立场反复的人，对吧？那是这个国家历史上最重要的法案之一。托马斯·爱迪生（Thomas Edison），说到创新领域。爱迪生在试图开创电灯泡时，
while he was trying to pioneer the light bulb. He invented a talking doll so creepy that it scared not only kids, but adults too Talking doll. I've had nightmares looking at the picture of this and so it actually moved its mouth and words came out It did. Yeah, this is very early sort of free robot. He tried to you know mine He tried to mine iron with magnets He tried to preserve fruit with failing techniques, and he had to be willing to admit that these ideas were not working out to move on to the ones that did. But one of the things that this implies is that what distinguishes the great from the
致力于各种失败的发明。他发明了一个会说话的娃娃，它诡异到不仅吓坏了小孩，也吓坏了大人。会说话的娃娃。我看过这张照片的图片，做过噩梦，它竟然还会动嘴巴，说出话来。是的，这是一种非常早期的自由机器人。他试图，你知道的，用磁铁开采铁矿。他试图用失败的技术来保存水果，他必须愿意承认这些想法行不通，才能转向那些行得通的想法。但这意味着的一点是，区分伟大与
ordinary is not necessarily that the great only have great ideas, but that the great simply have many more ideas in the ordinary. I think that's exactly the story, right? The greatest originals are the people who failed the most, because they're the ones who tried the most. If you study this across lots of different domains, it's not that originals have higher hit rates than their peers. It's just they generate more volume,
平凡的，不一定是因为伟大者只有好点子，而是伟大者比平凡者拥有更多的好点子。我认为这就是故事的真相，对吧？最伟大的原创者是那些失败最多的人，因为他们是尝试最多的人。如果你在许多不同的领域对此进行研究，并不是说原创者的命中率比他们的同龄人更高。只是他们产出了更大的体量，
which gives them more variety, and a better shot at something new. So Bach, Beethoven, Mozart, they were not on average in a typical composition better than their peers, but they generated over 600 each. In cases over a thousand different compositions and a few of those were true masterpieces When you looked at the works of Shakespeare you also found that at the very same time Shakespeare was writing some of his greatest masterpieces He was also writing some of his greatest duds. Yeah, have you heard of the Mary wives of Windsor? What about the Tumon of Athens? If Shakespeare were here today He'd want want us to know that around that time he also wrote Hamlet and Macbeth.
这为他们提供了更多的多样性，以及获得新事物的更好机会。所以巴赫、贝多芬、莫扎特，他们在一首典型作品上的平均水平并不比他们的同龄人更好，但他们每个人都创作了600多首作品。在某些情况下甚至有一千多首不同的作品，而其中有几首是真正的杰作。当你审视莎士比亚的作品时，你也会发现在莎士比亚创作他最伟大的杰作的同时，他也在创作他最糟糕的烂作。是的，你听说过《温莎的风流娘们》（The Merry Wives of Windsor）吗？《雅典的泰门》（Timon of Athens）呢？如果莎士比亚今天在这里，他会想让我们知道，大约在那个时候他还写了《哈姆雷特》和《迈克白》。
So what explains this when the same person is sitting down in writing plays or the same person is sitting down and doing inventions, how is it that they're producing genius and crap at the same time? One because a lot of us fall in love with our first ideas, and those are the most conventional. Often you have to weed out the familiar in order to get to the unusual but a lot of people never get to those later ideas. A second thing is it's just really hard to judge your own ideas. Most of us are way too positive on the ideas we come up with and oftentimes they need to put a bunch of ideas out in the world. They could feedback and find out what actually
那么，当同一个人坐下来写剧本，或者同一个人坐下来搞发明时，是什么解释了这一点：他们怎么能同时产出天才之作和垃圾呢？首先是因为我们很多人都爱上了自己的第一个点子，而那些点子是最传统的。通常你必须剔除熟悉的东西才能得到不同寻常的东西，但许多人从未达到那些后面的点子。第二件事是，评判自己的想法实在是太难了。我们大多数人对我们想出的点子过于乐观，而且往往他们需要把一堆点子放到世界上。他们可以得到反馈，并找出真正
made sense. I'm wondering if the same thing is true of Shakespeare. If we actually sat Shakespeare down the year after he wrote the Mary Wieser, and Macbeth, is it possible that he might have told us, you know, Macbeth, it's okay, but the Mary Wieser wins, that's the masterpiece. You know, this is so common among originals. I can't tell you what Shakespeare would have said obviously because he didn't answer my interview request. But you know, you see this with scientists all the time, that frequently their least-sided works are the ones that they think are the greatest.
合理的东西。我想知道莎士比亚是否也是如此。如果我们真的让莎士比亚在他写完《温莎的风流娘们》和《迈克白》的一年后坐下来，他有没有可能告诉我们：“你知道的，《迈克白》还行，但《温莎的风流娘们》才是杰作。”你知道的，这在原创者中太常见了。我显然无法告诉你莎士比亚会说什么，因为他没有回复我的采访请求。但是，你知道的，你总是能在科学家身上看到这一点，通常他们引用最少的作品才是他们认为最伟大的作品。
And Beethoven. Beethoven was known as a great self-critic, and yet he was pretty far off the mark in predicting which of his pieces were going to be his biggest hits and his biggest flops. My guest today is Adam Grant. He's a professor at the Wharton School. Coming up, we talk about who gets the chance to be original and how parents can foster this quality in their kids. I want to look a little bit at perhaps what might be called the dark side of originality or maybe the dark side is not right the right word It's more that the benefits of originality are not distributed equally in our society
还有贝多芬。贝多芬被称为伟大的自我批评家，然而他在预测自己的作品中哪几首会成为最大的热门和最大的滑铁卢时，却相当偏离目标。我今天的嘉宾是亚当·格兰特。他是沃顿商学院的教授。接下来，我们将讨论谁有机会成为原创者，以及父母如何在孩子身上培养这种品质。我想探讨一下可能被称为原创性的黑暗面，或者也许说黑暗面不是正确的词，更确切地说，原创性的好处在我们的社会中并没有得到平等的分配。
Yeah, I think this is a great tragedy that we see both women and racial minority groups being less likely to speak up when they have original ideas Cheryl Sandberg and I wrote an op-ed about this last year called speaking wall female and we covered a bunch of evidence including some of some studies that I ran showing that when men spoke up they were rewarded for it and when women spoke up either they were barely heard and usually some dude like sort of wanders in and steals credit for their idea or they were judged as too aggressive and violating these communal caring stereotypes we have of women. And I think those stereotypes lead a lot of women to hold back because they're afraid of backlash. And I think that we need many more organizations and I think people in the world to check their biases and be receptive to both women and minority groups bringing their ideas to the table.
是的，我认为这是一个巨大的悲剧，我们看到女性和少数族裔群体在有原创想法时不太可能大声说出来。谢丽尔·桑德伯格（Sheryl Sandberg）和我去年就此写了一篇专栏文章，名为《身为女性大声说出》（Speaking While Female），我们涵盖了一堆证据，包括我做的一些研究，这些研究表明，当男性大声说出来时，他们会因此得到回报，而当女性大声说出来时，要么她们几乎无人倾听，通常某个家伙会过来窃取她们想法的功劳，要么她们被认为太好斗，违反了我们对女性的这种社群关怀的刻板印象。我认为这些刻板印象导致许多女性退缩，因为她们害怕遭到反弹。我认为我们需要更多的组织，我认为世界上的每个人都需要审视自己的偏见，并乐于接受女性和少数族裔群体将他们的想法带到桌面上来。
But you have to wonder how many great ideas are not being put on the table at all because people feel hesitant to talk about them. Yeah, I think we're missing out on the majority of the original ideas in the world, not because people aren't creative, but because there's a gap between the ideas you have and the ones that you share. And if you go back to this idea about the volume of ideas, sort of creativity relationship that we talked about earlier, history is obviously full of examples of men doing the majority of the original work in certain fields. And that's largely because they had the freedom to work on lots
但你不得不怀疑，有多少伟大的想法根本没有被提出来，因为人们对谈论它们感到犹豫。是的，我认为我们错过了世界上大多数的原创想法，不是因为人们不具有创造力，而是因为你拥有的想法与你分享的想法之间存在差距。如果你回到我们之前讨论过的关于想法数量与创造力关系的观点，历史上显然充满了男性在某些领域完成大部分原创工作的例子。这在很大程度上是因为他们有自由去从事许多
of ideas, whereas women were primarily, you know, working on childcare and they had a hard time getting their ideas heard. In the book you talk about the idea that birth order, whether you have older siblings or younger siblings, might play a role in your willingness to take chances. Can you talk about that work? This is wildly controversial. I don't think I've ever seen another realm of social science with more competing results. But there are a series of studies suggesting that first borns tend to be slightly more conventional achievers, whereas later borns are more inclined to challenge the status quo and do things that
想法的工作，而女性主要在照顾孩子，而且她们很难让自己的想法被听到。在书中，你谈到了出生顺序（无论你是有哥哥姐姐还是弟弟妹妹）可能会在你的冒险意愿中发挥作用的观点。你能谈谈那项研究吗？这极具争议。我想我从未见过社会科学的另一个领域有如此多相互冲突的结果。但有一系列研究表明，长子往往是稍微传统一些的成就者，而晚生儿则更倾向于挑战现状并做一些
are a little bit original. And get this. You look at over 300 pairs of brothers who played professional baseball, and that way you get to do the test within families, and you see that younger brothers are more than 10 times more likely to attempt to steal a base than their older siblings. So why is that? I think that one factor that the popular explanation from Frank Zulloy is that it's about niche picking, that, you know, it's hard to stand out by being
有点原创的事情。不仅如此。你看看300多对打过职业棒球的兄弟，这样你就可以在家庭内部进行测试，你会发现弟弟试图盗垒的可能性比他们的哥哥高出10倍以上。这是为什么呢？我认为弗兰克·苏洛伊（Frank Sulloway）的一个流行解释是关于生态位选择，你知道的，要通过比你的哥哥姐姐更聪明或更强壮来脱颖而出是很困难的，他们在学业和运动上都有明显的优势。所以你要做的是寻找其他脱颖而出方式，其中之一就是冒险或具有创造力。不过，我认为故事的另一部分是，父母往往会给他们后出生的孩子更多的自由。你训练人们具有原创性的方法是什么？你在一个公司、一个组织、一个家庭中鼓励原创性的方法是什么？让我们从家庭方面开始。如果你研究一些美国最具原创性的建筑师，并将他们与技术精湛但创造力较差的同龄人进行比较，创意建筑师家庭中发生的事情之一就是他们的父母
smarter or stronger than your older siblings that have a clear advantage academically and athletically. So what you do is you look for other ways to stand out, and one of those is to take risks or be creative. I think the other part of the story, though, is that parents tend to give more freedom to their later born children. What is the way you train people to be original? What is the way you encourage your originality in a company and an organization in a family? Let's start with the family side of it. If you study some of the America's most original architects and compare them with technically scaled but less creative peers, one of the things that happened in the families of the creative architects was their parents
更关注价值观而不是规则。他们会说这样的话，你知道的，卓越在这个家庭中很重要。你想取得什么样的成功？或者我们真的很关心我们的行动对他人产生的影响。你想在你周围的世界留下什么样的印记？当他们的孩子长大了，他们有了一套非常明确的指导原则。他们愿意坚守阵地
focused more on values than rules. And they would say things like, you know, excellence is important in this family. What kind of success do you want to achieve? Or we really care about our actions having an impact on others. What sort of mark would you like to make on the world around you? And when their kids grew up, they had a very clear set of guiding principles. They were willing to stand their ground
当其他人不同意他们的观点时。他们不仅考虑创造性的自我表达，还思考如何做一些对其他人有用事情。但为什么基于规则的行为不会产生与基于价值观的建议相同的结果呢？当你在家庭中关注规则时，很多时候孩子学会了遵守规则，
when other people didn't agree with them. And they also thought a lot about not just creative self-expression, but saying, how can I do something that's useful to other people? But why is it that rules-based behavior doesn't produce the same thing as values-based advice. When you focus on rules in a family, a lot of times kids learn to follow them,
这意味着接受现状并本质上成为一头优秀的绵羊。而当你转向价值观时，孩子们实际上必须自己思考。你知道的，作为父母这很有趣，对吧？因为在阅读了这项研究后，我不断地发现自己，每当我们的孩子表现不好时，就会说：“新规则！”然后意识到，不对，我们应该讨论这个规则背后的价值观是什么。
which means accepting the status quo and essentially becoming an excellent sheep. And when you go to values, kids actually have to think for themselves. What's, you know, this is funny as a parent, right? Because after reading this research, I'm constantly catching myself, every time our kids misbehaved, saying, new rule! And then realizing, nope, we should be talking about what's the value behind this rule.
给我一个最近发生这种事的例子。好吧，所以我们坐在晚餐桌前，你知道的，我们的家庭价值观之一是尊重。所以我们希望他们在每个人都吃完饭之前不要离开餐桌。然后，你知道的，他们开始站起来，就像是“不，你必须坐在你的座位上”。然后我开始意识到我需要说的是：这就是为什么这对我们很重要。这不是关于拥有规则，而是关于说，听着，我们喜欢大家坐在一起的
Give me an example where that's happened recently. All right, so we're sitting at dinner and you know, one of our family values is respect. So we like for them to not get up from the dinner table before everyone's done eating. And you know, they start to get up and it's like, no, you must sit in your seat. And then I start to realize what I need to say is here's why that's important to us. It's not about having the rules, it's about saying, look, the reason we like to all sit
座位是因为我们希望每个人都能分享一顿美好的家庭晚餐。我们认为这是彼此尊重的绝佳方式。所以我认为，当你谈论原创性和创造力时，我们的社会存在着一种巨大的渴望，想要培养人，想要让员工具有原创性，并且具有创造力。原创性和创造力有负面影响吗？是的，当然。几年前，巴里·施瓦茨（Barry Schwartz）和我写了一篇关于“物极必反”效应（too much of a good thing effect）的论文，我们基本上认为所有的力量和美德都像金发姑娘效应一样，你可能会拥有太多，也可能会拥有太少。
in our seats is because we want everybody to share a nice family meal. And we think that's a great way to have respect for each other. So I think when you talk about originality and creativity, there's a great hunger in our society to want to race people, to want to have employees, be original, and be creative. Are there downsides to originality and creativity? Yeah, of course. A few years ago, Barry Schwartz and I wrote a paper on the too much of a good thing effect, where we basically argue that all strengths and virtues are like Goldilocks, where you can have too much as well as too little.
毫无疑问，原创性也是如此。风险之一是每个人都朝着不同的方向前进，先驱者需要定居者，领导者需要追随者。如果每个人都是原创者，那么你就没有人来帮助实施你的想法。但我认为对立面是更大的风险。如果每个人都顺从，那么我们就失去了改善周围世界的绝佳方式。我不想让人们顺从，这基本上是在说，
And there's no question that with originality that can be true. One of the risks is that you have everybody marching in a different direction, and pioneers need settlers, leaders need followers. If everybody's in original, then you don't have anyone to help implement your ideas. But I think the opposite is a greater risk. If everybody conforms, then we lose out on great ways to improve the world around us. And I don't want people to conform, which is basically saying,
我会顺从你的想法，尽管我不相信它。我希望他们自己思考，有时决定别人的想法是值得追随的。我不想离开。亚当·格兰特，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常高兴。Hidden Brain播客由Karam Agar Kalasin、Maggie Pennman和Max Nestra制作。我们还有一个非常棒的时事通讯，里面有每周节目背后的更多科学和故事，以及来自网络各处的精彩链接。你可以通过发邮件给HiddenBrain@NPR.org，主题写“订阅”来获取它。
I will go along with your idea even though I don't believe in it. I want them to think for themselves and sometimes to decide that other people's ideas are worth following. I don't want to go. Adam Graham, thank you so much for joining me on Hidden Brain today. Such a delight. The Hidden Brain podcast is produced by Karam Agar Kalasin, Maggie Pennman and Max Nestra. We also have a really great newsletter with more science and stories behind each week's episode and great links from around the web. You can get it by emailing the word subscribe to HiddenBrain at NPR.org.
我们也在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上，你可以在当地的公共广播电台听到我的其他社会科学故事。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。谢谢。这个剧集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。
We're also on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and you can hear my other social science stories on your local public radio station. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. 감사합니다. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们也在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上，您还可以在当地的公共广播电台听到我的其他社会科学故事。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。谢谢。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。